♪ That's Vinny and the Colonel
- Goddamit Colonel, what
the fuck were you doing?
- I was making sick beats.
- How do you break
a turntable in half?
- I mean, they were some
really sick beats, Vinny.
- You have no respect
for other people's stuff.
- I have no respect for
other people's stuff?
You fucked Sandra Conley even
though she was my girlfriend!
You have no respect for
other people's stuff!
- Sandra Conley
isn't stuff, Colonel,
and that was ten years
ago, get over it!
- Oh I'm over it, Vinny.
I'm over you!
I'm done lettin' ya boss
me around, ya fuckface!
- Buy me this turntable.
- Okay, this is the last time
I let you boss me around.
(turntables scratching)
Let me help you
set it up, Vinny.
- No that's okay,
you might break it
with your sick beats, which
aren't sick at all, by the way.
- What are you
tellin' me, Vinny?
- I'm telling you
your beats suck.
(Colonel gasps)
Yeah that's right.
But not on the dicks
people like to suck.
Your beats suck on the
bad kinds of dicks.
Nightmare dicks.
- You watch it, Vinny.
One of these days you're
gonna push me too far,
and you'll be sorry!
- Oh yeah and that
reminds me, tell your mom
I said thanks for the hot sex.
- What did you just say to me?
- Last week, at Dave's party,
I fuckin' banged your mom, man.
I banged her good, tossed
her dirty tuna salad,
and she fuckin' loved it.
- I'll kill you, you fuck!
(scuffling)
(turntable crashes)
(loud puff)
- Damn, 30 years in
that crap ass turntable.
Feels good to stretch my legs,
let these fuckin' nuts hang.
Y'all got any Percocet?
- Uh, no.
- Who the heck are you?
(turntables scratching)
♪ Well I'm Manzini the Genie
♪ And I'm here to say
♪ You got three
wishes comin' your way
♪ But there's just one rule
before I grant your wishes
♪ I don't grant shit
to no mark ass bitches
And still, if you know anywhere
I can score some pills,
holla at your boy.
- Whoa a genie!
What are we gonna
wish for, Vinny?
- We?
Why would you get wishes?
It's my turntable.
- I bought it, though.
- With money you
stole from your mom!
- Who you banged apparently!
- Dude, I was just
kidding about that.
- Oh, really?
- Nah, I totally
fucked her, man.
- Manzini the Genie ain't
got time for this shit.
You want your wishes or what?
- I don't even know why I'm
friends with you, Vinny.
You stole Sandra,
you fucked my mom.
My entire life sucks
because of you!
- Your life sucks because of me?
My life sucks because of you!
I wish we'd never met!
(turntables scratching)
♪ You hate him and he hates you
♪ You wish you never met and
that's somethin' I can do
♪ I'm Manzini bitch and
by the power of my rhymes
♪ Wish granted muthafucka
♪ I'm the best of all time
(coughing)
- Oh what's happening?
- This is your wish, Vinny.
This is your life had you
never met Colonel Peppersnacks.
- What's wrong with me?
- You're dyin', bitch!
- Dying, but, but how?
- Well have you
ever seen that movie
The Dallas Buyer's Club?
- I have AIDS?
- Oh no, no.
You were working on
the set and got cracked
in the dome with a light.
(light shatters)
- Damn well, at least
I work in movies.
That's pretty cool, am
I producer or something?
- No, you're a
production assistant.
You get bagels,
you're a bagel bitch.
- Shit, so wait,
I'm dying because
I got hit in the
head with a light?
- Not exactly.
Have you ever that movie
The Fault in Our Stars?
- What, did I like
work on that movie too
and fall off a crane?
- Nah, you got cancer.
- Oh.
- When they brought you in
for the bump on your head,
they discovered the lung cancer,
as well as the
cirrhosis of your liver.
Oh, and now that I'm
looking at ya charts here,
ya actually do have AIDS.
Must be from all
the dirty needles
and prostitutes, ya sick fuck.
- And this is what
my life is like?
All because I never met Colonel?
- Yup.
- Well, if my life
sucks this bad,
Colonel's must be
a pile of shit!
- Guess again, dick nose.
(remote control clicks)
(crowd cheers)
- I just wanna thank
everyone on my staff,
but most importantly, I'd like
to thank my dear wife Sandra.
She inspired me to
run for President.
She was also instrumental
in passing the legislation
that allowed the acceleration
of Stanford University's
stem cell research program.
What's that?
What did you say?
Ladies and gentleman,
I've just been informed
that the research I have
just mentioned earlier
has led to the cure
for all known diseases.
(television powers off)
- Colonel is the president?
- Yeah, without you,
Colonel was able to reach
his full potential and make the
entire world a better place.
- But, he said they found the
cure for all known diseases.
So, I'm gonna be okay, right?
- Fuck no!
You're a production assistant,
you can't afford those drugs.
Your ass don't even get
benefits, ya little bitch.
- Fuck, what am I gonna do?
Can I wish it back?
I wish it back, I wish it back!
(turntables scratching)
♪ You didn't like the
wish that you made first
♪ So your second wish is
to throw it in reverse
♪ You wasted two wishes and
you're back at where ya startin
♪ Is it just me or is that
Well that's kinda
fuckin' retarded.
- Oh, you really, you
can't say that anymore.
- Bitch, I spent the last 30
years in a fuckin turntable.
I'll say whatever
the hell I want!
- Yeah that's not how
things work anymore.
- So, you can go
around talkin' about
fuckin' your friend's mom,
but I can't say retarded?
- Apparently.
- Man that's gay as hell.
(inhales sharply)
- Yikes, uh, let's just
um, let's just go back.
(loud puff)
- Whoa, where'd you guys go?
- I showed Vinny what
his life would be like
if you two had never met.
- What was it like, Vinny?
Were you better off without me?
Why would you wish
yourself back?
- Yeah, I mean it was
awesome, it was way better,
but it really would
have been selfish for me
to stay in that other
life, so I decided
to wish myself
back here, for you.
- Wow, that's amazing Vinny,
that's really nice of you.
(Manzini scoffs)
- Boy, his life wasn't awesome,
he was a bagel
bitch dyin' of AIDS,
and you was the
muthafuckin' President!
- What, Vinny is that true?
- Yeah, and you were
married to Sandra.
- Wow.
Fucking dick.
- Look Colonel, I'm sorry for
being such a shitbag to you
all these years, and
I'm really sorry that
I banged Sandra
out from under you.
It turns out I need you
way more than you need me.
I wanna make up for all that.
I want you to have
the last wish.
- Alright, well, I think I
know what I wanna wish for.
- I'm begging you, Colonel,
please don't wish for that.
I was dying, man, dying
alone in a crappy hospital.
I don't wanna die, I
don't wanna be alone.
- Look at this gay boy beggin'
for his retarded ass life
like a little bitch.
Sack up, nigga!
- Dude, you can't
say those things!
- Dude, it's a whole thing
with him, don't even bother.
- Now, about your wish.
- I just want things to go
back to how they were, Vinny,
before I broke your turntable.
- What?
- You said you needed me, Vinny.
That's all I've
ever wanted to hear.
I just want things to go
back to the way they were.
You're my best friend.
- Well Colonel,
I don't know what to say.
That's all I want too, man.
- I'll bet you do,
ya piece of shit!
(flatline)